taliban fighters reportedly captured a
district in northern afghanistan this
morning it's part of an offensive
against afghan forces in more than 20
provinces as u.s troops start to leave
the country for good
charlie dagetta spoke to afghanistan's
number two leader who says the u.s made
fundamental errors
ahead of the pull out
huge surge in violence across the
country has proved taliban militants
were never going to honor u.s assurances
to hold back attacks
for first vice president amrola saleh
it's self-evident
taliban are terrorists and temple
do you trust the taliban no at all no
he said it was a mistake for america to
negotiate with the taliban in the first
place
and president biden's justification for
the pull out
we degraded the terrorist threat of
al-qaeda in afghanistan
he says that was misguided too the whole
idea of coming to afghanistan
was to teach a lesson
to terrorists their allies
don't do it again have we taught them
that listen
no says his soldiers have killed or
captured dozens of al-qaeda fighters in
the last few days alone
taliban operates shoulder to shoulder
with al-qaeda today he survived several
assassination attempts
including when a suicide bomber and
gunman killed 20 people
in an attack on his office with the
withdrawal of u.s forces and
nato allies saleh knows afghanistan
faces
a dangerous few months ahead but says
if there's any hope of peace the taliban
need to stop
legion war at the end of the day
taliban cannot subdue afghanistan
through the barrel of the gun
they can kill people they are killing
people every day
but if they are waiting for a moment of
surrender from the afghan people
it won't come
the vice president started by saying he
was grateful to america
for the lives lost here and the vast
amount of money spent but in his words
he said we need the u.s to remain
engaged diplomatically economically
and strategically tony it's a powerful
interview there with the vice president
of afghanistan charlie thank you very
much
coming to us from kabul